neue studie mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
hat die raumsonde cassini spuren von
leben auf dem saturnmond enceladus
entdeckt hinweise darauf spürte ja die
raumsonde cassini auf denn die fontänen
dort aus eispartikeln und wasserdampf
enthalten auch methan und das könnte von
mikroben stammen wie wahrscheinlich ist
also außerirdisches leben auf dem saturn
und wirklich alle spannenden infos zu
dieser spektakulären frage gibt es jetzt
bei pixum science and future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen minus 200
grad celsius und eis bedeckt
lebensfeindlicher als die umgebung auf
dem saturnmond enceladus kann es auf den
ersten blick erst einmal gar nicht sein
doch möglicherweise ist es ganz anders
als es scheint denn die sonde cassini
der nasa hatte bei einem vorbeiflug eine
spannende entdeckung gemacht nahe des
südpols treten dampf und eis schwaden
aus wasserstoff methan und anderen gasen
aus und das aus dem kilometer dicken
eispanzer von enceladus für eine genaue
analyse hat die nasa dann ein
spektakuläres manöver möglich gemacht
cassini flog später sogar mehrmals durch
die fontänen die große frage hierbei
stammt dieses methan tatsächlich von
leben unter diesem eispanzer genau
dieser spannenden frage ist jetzt ein
internationales forschungsteam genauer
nachgegangen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben ganz konkret die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür berechnet
welche ursache die wahrscheinlichste für
diese entdeckung ist und die
erkenntnisse sind spektakulär kommen wir
damit jetzt endlich dem außerirdischen
leben auf die spur alle spannenden facts
die wir bisher zum thema wissen gibt es
in diesem video
fakt ist unter der dicken eisschicht von
enceladus befindet sich wohl ein etwa 37
kilometer tiefe ozean aus flüssigem
wasser das hatten forschungsteams
bereits mit hilfe der messungen der
nasa-sonde cassini herausfinden können
der grund dafür sind möglicherweise
gezeigten effekte des saturns der planet
wald und knetet seine mond so richtig
durch zudem treten aus rissen
in der nähe des enceladus südpols
tausende kilometer hohe dampf von ten
heraus und diese enthalten tatsächlich
alle wichtigen zutaten für leben
stickstoffverbindung wie methan gütern
und penta und salze aber wasser
sauerstoff und kohlenstoff die fachwelt
geht deshalb davon aus dass es auf dem
meeresgrund von enceladus heiße quellen
gibt mit temperaturen von bis zu 100
grad celsius vor allem methan gilt als
wichtiger hinweis darauf dass auf dem
saturnmond enceladus leben existieren
könnte
denn dieses spurengas entsteht
hauptsächlich bei biologischen prozessen
unter luftabschluss die auf
mikroorganismen zurückzuführen sind
derartige mikroorganismen
verstoffwechseln nämlich keinen freien
sauerstoff denen es ja in solchen
regionen sowieso nicht gibt stattdessen
produzieren sie aus kohlenstoff und
wasserstoff mit haben dieser prozess
wird in der fachsprache als methan og
sie bezeichnet somit gilt methan schon
seit langer zeit als biomarker bei der
suche nach leben in unserem sonnensystem
doch bei aller euphorie darf man eine
sache nicht vergessen es sind nicht nur
biologische aktivitäten durch die methan
entstehen kann auch geologische prozesse
kommen dafür infrage enceladus gilt
dennoch nicht nur als möglicher sondern
sogar als heißester kandidat für
außerirdisches leben könnte der saturn
und möglicherweise sogar der erde
ziemlich ähnlich sein fest steht in
solchen heißen quellen die auch auf
unserer erde existieren können methan
und wasserstoff entstehen die dort
vorhandene chemische energie ist
beispielsweise am irdischen meeresboden
in der nähe von so genannten schwarzen
rauchern für die reichhaltigen
ökosysteme dort fahren und gut möglich
also dass solche heißen quellen auf der
erde auch eine entscheidende rolle für
die entstehung von leben gespielt haben
könnte dass auf dem saturnmond enceladus
auch der fall sein genau diese frage
treibt forschende seit jahren um die
nasa raumsonde cassini hatte den saturn
zwischen den jahren 2004 und 2017
umkreist und dabei auch die monde
genauer ins visier genommen enceladus
ist der sechs größte mond von saturn und
zwar mit einem durchmesser von 500
kilometern bereits in der vergangenheit
gab es hinweise auf potenzielles leben
auf enceladus so hatte beispielsweise
ein österreichisches forschungsteam in
einem
experiment gezeigt das mikrobielle das
leben wie wir es von der erde kennen
auch auf enceladus möglich sein könnte
dazu nutzen die fachleute
mikroorganismen aus der gruppe der arche
die extreme bedingungen wie hohe
temperaturen und druck aushalten
diese mikroben mit der bezeichnung
methan oder thermo cocos akin avensis
ich hab's geschafft kommt vor allen
dingen der okinawa senke vor fast 1000
meter unter dem meeresspiegel befindet
sich an eigentlich lebens fand ja ort
zudem verstoffwechseln diese
mikroorganismen die in der fachsprache
auch metallo gene genannt werden
wasserstoff und kohlendioxid konkret
nutzen sie molekularen wasserstoff h2
als energiequelle und kohlendioxid co2
als kohlenstoff und energie quelle
pumpen methan ch4 zu erzeugen in ihrem
experiment damals simulierten die
fachleute die astronomische geologischen
und die chemische physikalische
umweltbedingungen des saturnmondes
enceladus besonders interessierte sie
dabei die forschungsfrage wie hoch die
methan produktivität der methanol gene
war
in den experimenten zeigte sich schnell
dass diese mikroorganismen unter den
bedingungen die der saturn und bietet
sogar vermehrungsfähige sind dazu
schrieb das forschungsteam damals wir
haben gezeigt dass metallo gene unter
enceladus ähnlichen bedingungen
vermehrungsfähige sind und ein teil des
in den wasser als fontänen
nachgewiesenen ch4 daher prinzipiell
biologischen ursprungs sein könnte
selbst bei einem druck von 50 bar waren
die japanischen tiefsee mikroben noch in
der lage sich zu vermehren
beim noch höheren druck allerdings nahm
die aktivität ab das im labor simulierte
enceladus mehr zeigt aber auch dass sich
auch noch weitere archea vermehren
konnten das forschungsteam aus wien kam
damals zu dem ergebnis das zitat eis
monde wie enceladus oder der jupitermond
europa der ebenfalls einen
unterirdischen ozean besitzt gute
aussichten bieten außerirdisches leben
zu entdecken wie wahrscheinlich ist es
also das methan durch eine biologische
aktivität entsteht genau dieser frage
ist das internationale forschungsteam
jetzt in der neuen studie nachgegangen
die zutaten für diese analyse eine menge
statistik und alle möglichen daten die
cassini bereits gesammelt hat gemixt
wurde das dann mit allem wissen über
biologische geochemische und
geophysikalische prozesse konkret nahm
das forschungsteam die sogenannte weiße
statistik zu hilfe ich hoffe ich habe es
jetzt richtig ausgesprochen
mit dieser methode können die
wahrscheinlichkeiten verschiedener
szenarien auf der grundlage von
begrenzten beobachtung berechnet werden
auch wenn die anfangs bedingungen zum
teil nicht bekannt in können fachleute
somit sachverhalte analysieren
hier also die frage bietet enceladus
tatsächlich lebensfreundliche
bedingungen und wie hoch ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das methan von
leben stand das ergebnis fasst das
forschungsteam folgendermaßen zusammen
die beobachtete menge an methan lässt
sich nicht allein durch nicht
biologische veränderungen des felsigen
untergrunds erklären sprich ja demnach
muss es eigentlich leben dort geben die
verhältnisse und mengen von methan und
wasserstoff auf enceladus sind demnach
gut mit der existenz von methanol den
lebensformen vereinbart die forschung
gehen sogar noch weiter ihrer ansicht
zufolge könnten die lebensfreundliche
bedingungen auf enceladus bereits seit
einigen milliarden jahren gegeben sein
eine lange zeitspanne also für die
entstehung von leben die frage ist nun
ob dort dann tatsächlich auch leben
entstanden ist eine zufriedenstellende
antwort auf diese frage gibt es nicht
vielmehr müsste man zunächst eine andere
frage beantworten verläuft die
entstehung von leben bei geeigneten
bedingungen eher zufällig und eher
selten oder entsteht leben unter
geeigneten bedingungen möglicherweise
sogar gesetzmäßig zwangsläufig falls die
entstehung von leben auf der erde kein
unwahrscheinlicher zu fall ist könnte
man ableiten dass tatsächlich mikroben
als wahrscheinlichste ursache für das
methan auf dem saturnmond in frage kommt
die andere möglichkeit wäre demnach dass
es vorgänge gibt bei denen methan
erzeugt wird diese uns aber bislang
völlig unbekannt sind der aktuellen
studie zufolge bis das vorkommen von
mikroorganismen auf enceladus aber das
wahrscheinlichste szenario allerdings
nur unter der bedingung dass dort
überhaupt leben entstehen kann und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür hoch genug ist
und dafür gibt es ja immer mehr indizien
dass nämlich die grundsubstanz für alles
leben aus dem weltall stammen sind wir
außerirdische das wirklich eine
spektakuläre entdeckung also anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren klicks konstanz
im future einfach auf den abo button
klicken hier unterm video
los gehts und zwar kostenlos klick klick
klick als uns ist dann halt dran